well to order the special committee on
the Family Division of the circuit court
for May 2nd
2023. some opening remarks from me I've
been encouraged by senior leadership to
give these remarks marks and in a
smaller version at the beginning of each
of our meetings
for the record I am representative Mark
Pearson chairman of the special
committee on the Family Division of the
Circuit Court it is Tuesday Morning May
2nd
2023. God willing we will be meeting on
May 9th 16th and 23rd at 9 30. we will
be taking the day after Memorial day off
we may meet one or more of the first
three Tuesdays in June we are
investigating the possibility of a field
trip to spend a morning in attendance at
Family Court somewhere in New Hampshire
on several of the days this spring we
will be hearing presentations from
various of the stakeholder groups
mentioned in the memorandum of April 10
2023 from the speaker's office
establishing the special committee
today we will be hearing from the dcyf
and from the Guardians at litem
next week we hope to hear from the New
Hampshire legal assistance particularly
from their domestic violence advocacy
Project Director and from the New
Hampshire Bar Association family law
section and the bar association pro bono
governing board
we hope to schedule presentations from
Child Support Services and individuals
from oplc the office of professional
licensure and certification as needed
and is at the call of the chair we will
be asking for specific information in
person from the judicial branch
I want to spend a little bit of time
talking about a committee that operated
11 years ago and tell you at the end the
reasons I just told you what I did
there were two documents I wish to cite
documents that are part of the public
record that you may access if you wish
first the house Journal of March 21
the year 2012. it contains reports from
the committee for the redress of
grievances each report summarized
individual petitions with findings of
either
Grievous grievance founded Grievous
founded with recommendations or
grievance unfounded
the second document also in the public
record is a special report to the
Speaker of the House of Representatives
The Honorable William L O'Brien dated
November 19 2012 by representative Paul
ingbretson chair
it provides an extensive overview of how
the committee conducted its business the
procedures required of those submitting
petitions to the committee we have those
as well
forms the committee used in making
reports we will be developing those as
needed and interpretive rulings that is
to say guidance from the legislative
Ethics Committee I mentioned these two
documents because many people today
allude to that 2012 committee
with various degrees of understanding as
to what it actually was and what it
actually did
there were 28 petitions initially
submitted with one withdrawn by the
petitioner
to quote from the November 19th
committee report the majority of the
petitions claimed violations of due
process relating to the judicial branch
Family Division as well as Guardians at
Litem in divorce cases
other petitions involved alleged abuses
of parental rights
the best interests of the child and
other abuses of discretion or power by
decision makers this is a quote the
petitions sought relief against judges
marital Masters Guardians at Litem and
agently agency staff
disproportionately from the Department
of Health and Human Services
from the conquered monitor article last
modified September 29 2012 comes this
statement
the committee determined 20 of the 27
complaints were legitimate and
pronounced seven unfounded if you read
through the various documents coming
from this process 11 years ago you will
discover that reviews were done of court
cases in great detail
while the committee had no authority to
overturn Court decisions because of the
New Hampshire Supreme Court ruling of
Meryl V Sherburne 1818. nevertheless the
committee made recommendations against
certain judges and marital Masters being
mentioned by name and it made specific
recommendations for legislation
first I mention all of this to steer
people invoking the memory of this
committee for the redress of grievances
to inform themselves of what it actually
was and did before quoting it
and secondly to let anyone coming before
us to know in no uncertain terms we are
not round two of that committee we will
not be reviewing court cases but looking
only at slices
little sections of a case
nor will we be making specific
recommendations about any individual
those of you wishing to testify please
fill out a pink card
while you have only to write your name
I suggest but do not require that you
also put on the card your telephone
number and email address written very
legibly so that later as the committee
starts looking at specific categories of
alleged difficulties in the family court
system should we need more information
from you we can find you
it has been strongly suggested to me
that I read the notice and disclaimer
statement before every Committee hearing
those of you who get the house record
will recall that last week this notice
was on the back page I believe it will
continue to appear
but anyway I'm asked to read this so
here goes
the special committee on Family Division
of the Circuit Court was formed to
investigate allegations of the
irregularities including failure to
follow or enforce statutes
unwarranted waiver of or failure to
follow court rules delay in rendering
decisions denial of due process and
other procedural issues the committee
will conduct hearings relative to the
process of the Family Division of
circuit court and may make
recommendations for future legislation
the purpose of the committee is to
discover areas where changes in
procedure or changes in law regarding
the Family Division of the Circuit Court
might be made
the purpose of this special committee is
not to retry the cases of citizens who
disagree with the outcome of litigation
that is not what we're here for if you
wish to appeal there's an appellate
court you go to not here
members of the public will be given the
opportunity to testify and present
information to the committee because of
the number of people who may wish to
testify there may be a time limit
imposed on each person testifying which
is permissible under house rule 100.
appropriate subject matter for
testifying
will be limited
to specific instances of where there
seemed to be irregularities in process
procedure or adherence to rules and
statutes that's it
appropriate subject matter those
testifying about subject matter relating
to a court case or who submit
documentation relating to a court case
should know that both will be made part
of the public record
therefore subject matter that is either
confidential or may be under Co
should not be discussed should not be
submitted to the committee as disclosure
of such matters would be a violation of
Statute or a court order
the committee reserves the right not to
accept written or oral testimony or
materials which would in its judgment
violate the foregoing that's the end of
the specific statement and I'll close
with a few more things from me
now with that in mind
three things please should you wish to
testify here
number one that statement I just read
was a joint effort of myself the
speaker's office and the house legal
counsel it has passed legal muster
secondly of the things you may present
to us orally electronically or in
written form we as a committee do not
know what may be confidential or under
the seal how could we know therefore it
is entirely up to those bringing us
testimony to filter out those items lest
you find yourself in difficulty you the
one wishing to provide testimony are
solely responsible for not bringing
these matters forward
additionally under this point there may
be some items simple facts or broader
anecdotes that are not confidential or
under the seal that you nevertheless may
want to present quietly but not as
public testimony
because should they be brought forth in
form and they are accepted into the
record they become part of the public
record if you don't want the public to
have access to the record of that item
don't create the record and please don't
do or say or write anything that may be
hurtful or embarrassing to your children
third this is how your testimony shall
be presented to us
first of all give us your name
secondly please to the degree you can
remember
the date time courtroom and judge
where the alleged era of the Court took
place remember we're not trying a case
we're looking at a slice or a snapshot
and we need to be able to identify that
and then third give us the alleged error
what are you complaining about be
extremely brief say it in one phrase I
believe there was a violation of the
Rules of Evidence or the judge let the
other party introduce motion after
motion after motion tell us in a phrase
what your complaint is describe before
describe briefly why you think this is a
violation of court rules
and then five if you or your lawyer
objected at that time what was the
judge's ruling why did the judge say
what the judge said and why did the
judge do what the judge did
you will have five minutes at which
point the microphone your microphone
will be shut off
um if you wish to give us written or
electronic testimony it must be as brief
as five minutes if somebody were to read
it aloud if you cannot do this in five
minutes or less you're not following the
rules of what we want
those five items I gave can be done in
under five minutes
if your testimony does not follow you
may be cut off from speaking further if
written or electronic your testimony
will not be accepted by us in when we go
to consider things it won't be
considered
now remember the last sentence of that
notice and disclaimer the committee
reserves the right not to accept written
or oral testimony or materials which
would in its judgment violate the
foregoing
the reason for this is not to be mean
it's not to be insensitive to what
you're bringing us
but to remind you please we are not
the second round of the committee of
redress of grievances
we're going about our business in a very
different way so the manner in which the
testimony comes to us must serve that
purpose it must be usable if we're going
to get anything done
so testimony in a different form won't
be useful to us and therefore we won't
accept it we don't need it so give us
what we need so we can make the
suggestions for change that we would
like to
so
some of that will be read again next
week and the week after and with that in
mind
the chair now recognizes the good folks
from
dcyf to come on up and make a
presentation to us who they are what
they do
and um
suggestions and remember we're solving
problems here we're we're trying to be
making helpful recommendations so come
on
either one
four
hi good morning everybody Joe rips I'm
director dcif I'm joined today by
attorneys margison and Baker
um so if there's any questions or
thoughts about you know specifically
what happens in the courtroom they're
much better prepared to talk about it
than I am I'm really kind of at that
higher level who is the third person for
uh Baker and what was the first name we
just bought yeah Deanna okay 74 year old
ears and your Chief legal
I I wrote actually wrote that yeah yeah
thank you
she's legal director for kind of the the
you may great appreciate go ahead all
right so again I'm Joe rips from
director dcif wonderful to see everybody
this morning
um thank you chair for the guidance I
just had a few things that I wanted to
share I wanted to kind of first do a
very brief overview of what we do in the
in the space related to this commission
and a little bit about how the court
process works and then some ideas for
things that might be able to be thought
about differently or better
so first off really going to focus on
the child protection side of the house
because I think that's where this is
dcyf for those of you who are familiar
really focuses on both child protection
and juvenile justice but for today's
purposes it's going to focus on the
child protection side of that the way
the child protection system works you
know very very high level
things start with a call to intake
that's our 24 7 hotline somebody picks
up that phone takes information about
allegations of abuse or neglect we get
north of 20 000 calls to that hotline a
year
at that hotline what somebody's somebody
has to do is go through what those
allegations are and make a determination
that if those allegations are true would
they be abuse or neglect as a matter of
Law and if the answer to that question
is yes then it gets screened in for an
assessment or an investigation
we do just north of ten thousand
investigations per year assessments
investigations per year
at that point there's a couple different
things that happen one they're assessing
to see whether in fact abuse or neglect
as a matter of law has occurred and two
they do a risk assessment to understand
kind of what a family's needs and risks
are to determine are there any types of
supports or services that would be
helpful to that family to prevent abuse
or neglect from happening in the future
um only about 10 percent of
Investigations result in a substantiated
finding of abuse or neglect per year
and less than about a thousand per year
um child abuse neglect cases go to court
that's not how many are necessarily open
at any given time but that's how many go
to court in a given year right so you're
starting from north of 20 000 and the
ones that go to court are counted in the
hundreds so there's a you know quite a
filter that occurs through that process
um the times that we go to court really
fall into a couple a couple buckets
um the broad way to think about it the
Broadway that I think about it is
whenever we're going to do something
that would impinge Upon A Parent's
rights then we should be going to court
right so specifically if a child is
going to be removed from their home and
put into foster care some other type of
placement then we need to go to court
and once you go to court there's
judge oversight attorney oversight Casa
oversight Etc through that process or if
we're going to do something that's going
to otherwise you know impinge on a
parent's right say that we're limiting
the access of a parent to a child or
we're going to try to get a court to
order services for that family to try to
keep you know that family together and
safe
the work over the past few years has
shifted quite a bit
um you know back in 2015 the work really
did you know case work where we're
opening up a case with families really
happened only through the court process
and that's because laws had been changed
and funding had been changed in the
Years prior to reduce our ability to
offer voluntary services to families
that's all been reinstated around
2017-2018 in terms of resources and
funding so at this point if you looked
at the number of cases that we have open
that's after investigation we're opening
up you'd see a couple different shifts
you would see that the number of kids in
out of Home Care have decreased over the
past few years you would also see the
number of in-home cases have increased
and you would see kind of a new category
that has grown and actually surpassed
the number of other types of cases which
we call prevention cases or voluntary
cases and those are cases where we're
working with a family either directly on
a voluntary basis or through a
contracted provider on a voluntary basis
so there have been major shifts in the
past few years to try to shift our work
away from always relying on court as the
intervention towards just being able to
help families out because families need
help and that's a big that's a big
change from the way that we had to do
business about five or six years ago
when really everything had to go through
court if you wanted to provide a service
to a family so that's kind of big
picture overview
um from where I sit you know I think the
dcyf's work with the family court has
been you know positive I think you know
there are uh processes in place if
there's disagreements on individual
cases right motions for reconsideration
and appeal processes
um there is also something called the
children and Court Improvement project
which has meetings once a month it
includes judges Court staff dcyf staff
parent attorneys children's attorneys
Casas judicial Council and they meet
monthly to talk about kind of how the
children in court process is working for
dcyf related matters and create
trainings and protocols and hosts of
other things sometimes come up with
recommendations for legislation that
have been passed in the years since I've
been here so you know from that level I
think that works quite well and it works
quite well because they get you know key
stakeholders from across different sides
of these issues to talk through what's
working what's not working and how to
make sure the process is working well
so big picture that's kind of you know
background on this if I wanna I can take
questions now or I can jump into some of
my thoughts about where we might be
thinking about doing better in the
future if folks would like
I'd like to give the committee a chance
to ask any questions of what we've heard
thus far representative long
thank you Mr chairman uh thank you Mr
ribson the um the appeals and
reconsideration process uh
what percentage is that at and would
that be would that percentage be of the
hundred that go to court
I don't know DNA or bathroom either of
you
so if I understand your question
representative long you're saying that
the appeals and reconsideration process
that is only for court involved cases
okay okay and what percentage uh follow
up for me follow up what percentage is
that I don't know I would have to ask
Deanna
we do not have data on that oh okay okay
thank you probably not a majority right
no
so dance behind it sorry that was quick
wow what what I would say is that um so
my position is the legal director
position that in 2017 was placed under
the supervision of the Attorney
General's office and so I am responsible
for the supervision of the entire dcyf
legal team which consists now of a lot
more attorneys thankfully to do the work
and because we are so connected now with
the Attorney General's office we are
regularly looking at cases that come
down that we disagree with and if we
need to we are having conversations
about the best approach to deal with the
case and we are also now able to take
cases to the New Hampshire Supreme Court
previously we were required to do a de
novo appeal and now we are taking cases
up and we are getting decisions and it's
been great
would you say that with the new and
improved and enlarged team on site and
appeals
this filters down so that judges will
say oh if this kind of thing is likely
to be appealed we won't do this kind of
thing so the number of appeals is
decreasing one would hope well so the
appeal process that's in place now has
not been in place for a really long time
so we're still too soon getting there
um I would say that anytime new judges
come on the bench we think to ourselves
oh I hope they've been trained really
well in child protection because there's
so many nuances to the work that we do
and director ribsum referred to those
protocols those are really helpful in
giving a road map not just to judges but
to everybody that's involved in the
child protection system
so we would hope that the soon to be
expanded amount of hours devoted to
continuing education of Judges that I'm
going to request will really get them up
to speed quickly and the number of
appeals would start to move down as the
system starts flowing better potentially
as new laws are enacted there's going to
be challenges to those laws so it's not
just dcyf that's able to appeal if
parent attorneys it's Casa every party
to our child protection cases can take a
case to the Supreme Court
for cause or just because they're
mandatory Appeals
oh
so they're accepted by the Supreme Court
so and we've seen a lot of actually an
increase recently in appeals from
permanency decisions um which is sort of
at the end of I'm sorry I can't see all
of you which is sort of at the end of
the 169 C Child Protection proceeding we
have something called a permanency
hearing and that's the point where we
ask the court to adopt a permanent plan
for a child which hopefully is
reunification
if not it would be adoption guardianship
or apple which is another planned
permanent living Arrangement just to
nail it down
um this is a mandatory appeal correct
the Supreme Court is taking them not
appeal for violation of law or process
just mandatory
I just want to make sure folks are clear
on the term mandatory there it's
mandatory in terms that the Supreme
Court must hear it if it is brought it's
not mandatory in the sense that an
appeal must be brought on every case
thank you representative
Smith
correct okay which is a very different
yes statements in mandatory appeals
thank you yes
any other questions from the committee
representative long I thank you Mr
chairman you'd spoke briefly on uh the
permanency hearings as one common uh I
was going to ask any particular appeals
or re or reconsiderations that stand out
to you other than it sounds like
permanency hearings are one of them is
there something else we frequently see
appeals from uh termination of parental
rights cases and now because we no
longer need to have a de novo appeal
before the Superior Court there are
appeals of 169 C adjudicatory and
representative McMahon
thank you Mr chairman Mr ripson you've
uh spoke of a children's Court
Improvement project that's ongoing and
based on the description of the special
committee on the on the family circuit
court is there a redundancy between that
existing committee and what we're now
initiating at this point
I don't know that I would call it a
redundancy because I think this this
committee has a broader purview that
really is focused specifically on the
processes that happen within a child
protection court case and a lot of it
really digs deeply into you know the the
protocols for how things could best
operate within court right so you have
of course you know your laws and you
have your court rules and this is a
group of people that come together to
try to make sure that on case-by-case
basis you know that not on Facebook but
that on individual cases
um the process is working well so I
think there's definitely some overlap
but I wouldn't call it a a redundancy
because I think your purview is broader
one follow-up Mr chairman follow-up uh
brief follow-up in the description of
this committee is to review
issues quote including failure to follow
or enforce statutes and the work for the
for the Improvement project is there any
reports or data you can provide this
committee on Finance in that regard yeah
so I think most of what they most of
what they uh release are comes out in
the form of kind of Court protocols and
how kind of the court process is
supposed to work and those those are
public and published so I imagine we
could provide those so that folks can
see you know kind of the the outcome of
that work okay thank you sir thank you
Mr chair and the chair is yet again
grateful that the committee researchers
are already typing out what I haven't
yet asked her but she knows I'm going to
and that is who are they on this when do
they meet and get me the reports thank
you
representative Smith
thank you um if I could just follow up
on my my colleague's comment isn't The
crucial difference that this is a
legislative committee and in terms of
separation of powers there are
opportunities and responsibilities that
the legislative branch has that
significantly differ from either the
administrative executive branch and the
judicial branch yeah Andy that makes
sense to me I'd agree
representative Lanza
thank you for taking my question
um so
um how many caseworkers do you usually
have and how how many how much is their
caseload when they have families that
they have to see yes so we have at this
point I think
if I'm talking just Frontline case
workers because we have folks that do
other types of case work so front line
that's our assessment workers that do
investigations and Family Service
workers who do you know these Court
types of cases that we're talking about
I think we have somewhere around
280 positions
I think we have currently about a 10
vacancy rate
um
which is you know better than it has
been and in the current climate you know
compared to what we're seeing in other
areas of state government it's you know
better than what we're we're seeing
which I think part of that I think that
has to do with a couple things one there
was work done over the last couple years
to adjust the salaries of Frontline
staff to make them more competitive with
other states and other types of jobs
which has helped bring people in and a
lot of work to try to reduce caseloads
which you know when I first got here
were in the 60s and currently are in the
The High Teens our goal for case loads
though is to get lower than we are today
so the goal for us for caseloads is that
we want to get to 12 cases per
assessment staff that's the folks doing
the investigatory work and 10 cases per
um family service worker those are the
folks that do the ongoing cases right
now our caseloads have been hovering
more in the mid the the mid to Upper
teens up to even 20 for assessment staff
and in the mid-teens around 15 14 for
family service staff
and there's a few things that have
contributed to that over the past few
years um particularly over this last
year
we've actually seen increased volume
over the past 12 months in terms of
calls to the hotline in terms of new
assessments and in terms of court cases
over the prior couple years so the
volume of work has actually grown even
though our Workforce has grown the
volume of work has also grown at the
same time and while I don't have good
debt on exactly what the driving forces
are behind that the anecdotal things
that I'm hearing from staff is that a
lot of it has to do with kind of what I
would call increased complexity or
Acuity of some of the families and cases
that we're working with particularly
related to things like Fentanyl
and and that being a substance that's
just simply deadly
compared to some of the other substances
that that we've historically been
working with
representative Greg thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for being here
and answering answering our questions
today I just wondered and I know that
the complexity of case to case is very
very different but do you have kind of
like an average
um how long these investigations and I
do know that there's going to be some
outliers either way but what your normal
length of time for doing an
investigation and kind of coming to
either found it or not found it is yeah
so the our protocol is that they're
supposed to be completed within 60 days
I think on average we see that they are
completed within 60 days but there are a
number that end up taking longer than
that for a number of reasons it could be
it could be within a discrete office
Workforce issues that are getting in the
way it could be complexities with
co-occurring law enforcement
investigations which when that occurs we
kind of Step into the front seat for the
purpose of child safety but they're kind
of in the front seat for the purpose of
investigatory processes so we kind of
take a step back to let them do what
they need to do from a criminal
perspective which means that you know
some of our investigatory processes kind
of get paused so there's a couple
different reasons why things could take
long longer than that but the I think on
average and by policy 60 days is the
time frame
follow-up
thank you so when it does take a little
bit longer is there some kind of
communication like you know not giving
specifics obviously because you can't
open up a case when it's still being but
saying like hey this is just going to
take a little bit longer or people just
kind of in limbo until it gets done yeah
there should you know caseworkers should
be having Communications with the
families that they're working with all
along there's requirements for for
contact on a monthly basis and
everything like that so there should be
in the um
I jotted it down quickly as children in
court Improvement project that may not
be the correct title exactly
did I get that wrong no I may have
written it wrong I may have gotten it
wrong too
well I'm not playing one dance manship
with you so stop it
it's the New Hampshire Court Improvement
Project New Hampshire Court Improvement
project okay
the group of us that are on the
committee are called the model Court
model the model the model m-o-d-e-l not
m-o-t-t-l-e yes
okay and you would be part of this I am
okay I have been since about
2009 I think 79 wow no not that one
any other questions for what we've heard
so far is seeing none
pick it up okay so a few few areas that
I have for recommendations and I I don't
know if how many of these would really
be a huge surprise to folks but you know
one of the pain points I currently hear
is you know access to bench time and
judge time right which comes down to
oftentimes you know the number of Judges
that we have available to hear cases I
do know that child protection cases tend
to get priority so you know if we are
having a hard time accessing I imagine
that other folks who have you know cases
before the family court have oftentimes
even more difficulty accessing I think
that often does come down to just simply
you know availability of judges and the
number of judges
um well we're working on that this
budget we are and I'm glad to see that
couple other things that come up a lot
that I think are worth the committee's
thought for the long term is thinking
about parental representation and better
support for that I believe there's
something in this budget process for
that as well but um we often have a hard
time having enough parent attorneys to
represent parents in these matters part
of that could come down to the the
funding and I do believe like I said
there's something in the budget this
year I haven't been following it closely
to address that issue but also in terms
of
um you know access to training and
resources and support for those family
attorneys that do parental
representation in these cases you know
in in New Hampshire because we're a
smaller State this has been established
essentially in a way that individual
attorneys out in the community get paid
an hourly rate to do this work other
jurisdictions set up kind of centralized
offices where you have staff attorneys
who do this work that specialize in it I
don't know you know I can't answer the
question as to whether our state is of
the size to support that I think that's
really a question for other folks to
weigh in on for the the towards the
judicial Council Etc but it is something
to think about I think in terms of being
able to make sure you have a pool of
attorneys that are are capable
well-educated supported in doing this
work
um
give me a guess as to how many dedicated
family attorneys I don't mean they're
dedicated to their job they're dedicated
to the task of being a family attorney
versus how many GP lawyers are you
having do family from time to time oh I
don't know that do you have any sense of
that's a that's difficult I think that
there's
always been sort of a core group of
attorneys who have represented parents
in um in our cases and many of them will
travel anywhere from Berlin to Nashua
um which is a huge swath and it's a huge
responsibility for those parent
attorneys to have to
do that work
numbers wise if I had to guess I would
say maybe 30 around the state
that regularly do it and and will take
appointments
and that's just a guess so I'm going to
beat this point to death therefore those
who are not dedicated
Specialists to this but do it sometimes
because it needs to be done
um are at a disadvantage that they are
not doing it full time and so therefore
there needs to be more training well I
think training is always a good thing
um and I think that of those 30 those
are the people that I'm saying like we
see regularly so we work with them
regularly they know the protocols they
know the statutes and they understand
the work there are certain times when
you know private attorneys will come
into our cases and they have no idea
what the general process is supposed to
look like and sometimes those cases can
go sideways yeah representative Smith
thank you when you are
talking about the need for more
attorneys specializing
um
are you also proposing that these
attorneys be compensated with public
funds
yes as long as you know the the way that
it currently works if the parents you
know qualify for
um for support on that then public funds
do support that so I think to the extent
that you know and that's an awful lot of
our cases an awful lot of our cases fall
into that bucket so yeah public funds
would need to be available to support
that work
representative ball
thank you chairman Pearson
excuse me I'm just curious if this list
of attorneys who specialize in this
field is that list provided to all the
parents or is it accessible to the
parents to know who to go to to
um so the courts generally know the
court clerks will know who in the area
is willing to take the work if we
um over the years if I've encountered an
attorney who I think would be good at
doing our work I would encourage them to
sign up with thank you
sign up with the um the court clerk in
their area that they're willing to take
the work but there's not a list that
parents can call and cold call attorneys
and ask them although they could call
any attorney in the state of New
follow up please follow up thank you so
in other words we don't have a situ um a
law or anything in place that entitles
parents at once they become involved
with dcyf that entitles them to be
provided with a list of recommended
attorneys they don't get a list of
recommended attorneys but they get
appointed an attorney immediately by the
court
so they at their first hearing will have
somebody there that is there for them to
work them through the process
great
um a couple other things that I would
just you know again put forward as ideas
for future work in this space
um you do see in other jurisdictions you
know parent attorneys having other types
of supports then then we are able to
offer them here and specifically what
I'm talking about is access to a social
worker who works directly with the
parent attorney and the parents and the
reason why that's valuable is right
oftentimes when dcyf is first involved
with the family there's going to be an
awful lot of distrust between the agency
and the parents right and we're we're in
an adversarial process a court process
as much as in these instances it's
interesting because our goals are often
aligned the goals of both parties are
typically to try to help heal the family
and reunify the family but
um nevertheless it is an adversarial
process and it is a process for which
you know it wouldn't shouldn't be a
surprise that a parent Who's involved in
that would be distrustful of the agency
at that time so the purpose in other
jurisdictions of having a social worker
work alongside of a parent's attorney is
to one give that parent somebody else to
talk to who can help kind of direct that
parent towards the right types of
supports and services and hope maybe
that person will be somebody the parents
a little more ready and willing to work
with than our own staff in those moments
where those tensions are high and
moreover to be able to have a closer
relationship with that parent that
they're representing one of the
challenges that you see is that you know
frankly attorney time is is expensive
and attorney time is is infrequent right
there's just not enough of it and that
was even true in the state that I last
worked in in New Jersey where we
actually did have a dedicated unit to
this
um even there it was hard for attorneys
to spend the amount of time with parents
to be able to develop that type of
trusting relationship and deep
understanding of what was happening
there that would be most beneficial to
help that parent move forward and
ultimately be successful in
reunification so the idea of injecting a
social worker into that process somebody
who's got you know maybe a different
skill set in terms of Engagement with
the parents a different skill set in
terms of connecting those parents to
resources and working alongside the
agency and connecting those parents to
resources and in general being able to
kind of speed up the hopefully the
timeline to reunification by getting
those parents the supports and services
that they need so did you have this in
New Jersey a dedicated social worker we
only had a handful it was a pilot
program at the time in New Jersey
there's other jurisdictions that use it
more broadly though
representative Smith
thank you Mr chair
um and who would employ uh these social
work and that's where I think it gets
really complicated in New Hampshire with
our current structure right where you
have basically individual attorneys out
there doing this work that are being
compensated on an hourly basis
um so I think that's something that
would have to be thought through you
know potentially with the judicial
Council I don't think it would be
appropriate for dcyf to be that entity
because you know we're in an adversarial
court process and if they're our
attorney or our social workers you're
not going to solve that kind of distrust
process that I'm talking about so I
think you'd have to look to some other
entity you know potentially judicial
counselor potentially you know some some
grouping of parents attorneys who'd be
willing to come together to support that
you may continue great
um the last big thing that I did want to
talk about was the idea of family
treatment Court
um
which uh is something that we've piloted
here in Sullivan County the courts
actually led the charge on that with
with us and many other stakeholders at
the table with Federal grant dollars and
this is essentially for folks who are
familiar to kind of the drug court model
for
um for uh adult criminal cases this is
kind of the the analog to that for child
protection cases and what you see in
these processes are
folks coming together more frequently
very very frequent Court hearings you
know oftentimes every two weeks of
course to support something like that
you need a lot more judge time and
attorney time and staff time and that's
really the the drain on on resources to
put forward something like a family
treatment court but you see really good
outcomes in terms of being able to get
those families who are struggling with
substance use and that being their
primary reason for not being able to
have their children to have them be
engaged in Services quickly have them
being kind of very regularly seen and
you know supported through the court
process and having all the stakeholders
who are part of this process that is
right the Child Protection Agency the
Casas the attorneys for the children
attorneys for parents
um
um all those folks kind of part of this
process on a regular basis with kind of
a Judicial oversight moving that through
it also creates kind of a forum locally
for folks to to Think Through how does
the treatment process work for parents
who are involved in the child protection
system and some space for local advocacy
around prioritizing access for parents
in these cases right because there's
obviously scarcity of resources
everywhere and at least in my own view
you know of all the people who need
resources and access to treatment
services folks who you know have young
children that they're responsible for
are are pretty high up on that list in
my view how long has this been going in
Sullivan County Sullivan County I think
the pilot started a couple years ago but
they actually just started taking it was
like a year of planning so they started
taking cases about a year ago there are
currently some conversations happening
about how to implement some of the best
practices from that in other courts but
there's not the resources in place to
actually duplicate a full-fledged family
treatment Court in other places have
they issued a preliminary report yet I
don't know that there's anything in
writing
I haven't seen anything in writing yet
but they're still in the trying it out
and sharing stage okay that'll be
fascinating to look at representative
Smith
thank you do you have any idea about
what percentage of
the child protection cases
um
have the problem centered around drug
use so if you're asking that question
from the perspective of what's coming in
to cause that intake that number is
actually smaller than people would think
but if you're asking that question from
the perspective of what goes to court
it's the majority of a substance use
involvement that go to court
so when I talked earlier about kind of
what we're seeing is this increased kind
of Acuity or complexity those cases
almost always involve substances and I
think if this I don't have an exact
number but it is probably the majority
of cases that go to court that have a
substance use dynamic thank you
representative long
thank you Mr chairman
um with respect to uh if
whether it's
a child in your system with parents and
you're working on reunification
um is there
an opportunity if there's been a civil
action or a criminal action against one
of the parents do you get those reports
and do you use those in your
determination
uh dude I get the questions yeah yeah
I believe I'm understanding your
question so if there's a criminal action
or another civil action like a marital
proceeding or a guardianship proceeding
um it depends a little bit criminal
cases we work jointly with law
enforcement so we often get access to
those records we can certainly reach out
to the court on non-confidential matters
to get access to the cases there have
been times where we are not allowed
access to guardianship cases because
they're confidential and so we then need
to file a motion to intervene in those
cases and typically the courts will let
us get the information we need to keep
Kids Safe
follow-up yeah just to um so you are
able to access you just
you just correct yeah so the court has
the court call center
um and thankfully the administrative
office of the courts worked with me
years ago to come up with a forum that
we can use that we can submit by email
to the court and somebody somewhere in
the court system I'm not sure exactly
who responds to us with the information
that we need
seeing no further questions uh thank you
attorney Baker
attorney margeson
and if you think of some other things
and want to come back in a month or
slice of time just let me know be happy
now we're going to look at the guardian
at litem
with uh
form a judge for the representative Ned
Gordon please come up sir thank you for
coming
um
and former Senator yeah
good morning everyone nice to see some
you used to park next to me he got your
for the record my name is Ned Gordon and
I am a member of the Guardian that light
on board I am a public member appointed
by the governor
uh to serve in that capacity
and have been for some time
and I guess you'd if you'd like me to
start with a statement I'll do that okay
and uh
I'm familiar with Guardian the litems uh
in three different capacities one is an
attorney uh who practiced and did some
family law
as a judge in which um I actually
appointed guardian of items in certain
circumstances
and as a senator
as a senator I actually sponsored the
legislation that created the guardian
that laid on board
back in the 1990s
prior to that
the guardian ad litems were appointed by
the court and there was and there was
authorization by Court rule to appoint a
guardian items guardian of items isn't
something that was created by New
Hampshire or is unique to New Hampshire
virtually every jurisdiction in the
country uses Guardian ad litems
but in our particular case up until the
1990s they were controlled pretty
exclusively by the court
and there were no real standards for
Guardian medal items that were
established at the time there were no
rules or standards for Guardian metal
items for their practice and there was
no system of discipline other than what
judges might impose and so there were
numbers of complaints at the time with
regard to Guardian of items and that's
what precipitated legislation back in
the 1990s to create a guardian that
light on board
regarding and to take that
responsibility for supervision from
Guardian lightens away from the courts
and actually put it into administrative
Services the guardian of item board fell
under administrative services
and the guardian that lied on board put
in place rules
established standards provided training
for Guardian nettle items
and they uh and and basically
professionalized guardian of items more
so than they were previously
prior to that
basically a judge could pick whoever
they wanted as a guardian that lied him
and in back in those days pick primarily
attorneys because that's who judges knew
as attorneys but
under the guardian of the item board you
don't necessarily have to be an attorney
to be a guardian I'd like them and I
have to say that many of the finest
Guardian lawyers I worked with weren't
attorneys
because basically a guardian that laid
him in many cases the best guardian of
the Lambs are ones that have good common
sense and that's not something
necessarily you can teach
so uh
the guardian of items the role that they
play in the state they play a really a
critical role in our state as they do in
other states there are certain
circumstances where Guardian that items
are mandated so just as you've heard in
the dcyf cases abuse and neglect cases
there's mandatory appointment and
guardian that'll items we have casa
who provides in a majority of the cases
across the state guarding that items and
abuse neglect cases if they're unable to
supply a casa guarding that light them
in an abuse neglect case then the court
will appoint a private Guardian Ad Litem
one who will agree to serve in that
capacity we appoint guardian of items
and termination of parental rights cases
mandatory appointment
in divorce cases it is not mandatory
appointment
and up until uh we had our financial
crisis in 2008
we used to the state used to pay for
Guardian ad litems in parenting cases in
divorce cases and parenting cases
and it uh
and that was uh and and and and and
which was
very helpful and
needed in many cases but in 2008 it was
decided that the state could no longer
I have to say you know from my own
experience having been a judge at the
time that probably we were appointing
too many Guardian adult items
um at the time because in cases maybe
where it just wasn't necessary because
it was convenient to do that and the
state was paying for it
but now I can say that there are
certainly many marital cases where a
guardian ad litem is needed and one
doesn't get appointed because there is
no means of paying for it
so right now we're a pointing guardian
of items when you can in marital cases
where you can find a means of paying for
the guardian that light them either
usually one or both of the parties to
pay for those Guardians that light them
and why do you need a guardian Adel item
you know I can tell you these
circumstances having sat there on the
bench
where uh one spouse is there saying I
need to have Primary Residential
responsibility for Johnny because
my ex over here he's got a new
girlfriend they do drugs they're stoned
every night they're selling drugs
there's people in and out of the house
every day
all the times of the day all times of
the night
we need to do something and and he's
only you know they're only sending the
school half the time
and so I need to have Primary
Residential responsibility
and then I say well geez you know what
do you say and the guy says well GC you
can't believe she's just saying that
because she's
getting benefits for having him in the
house that's not true at all and let me
tell you about their house she's got a
new boyfriend with a criminal record as
long as your arm he's beating her up
every night there's domestic violence in
the house
and the teacher tells me that Johnny
When Johnny Comes to school he wears the
same clothes every day he's dirty
and so you're there sitting as a judge
and you say well geez you know who do I
believe what do I do well it would be
really nice to have a guardian that
light him somebody who could go out
talk to the teachers find out what's
going on talk to somebody in the
community that understands talk to both
of the parents talk to Johnny and get a
sense of what's going on to help me make
a a good decision for what's in Johnny's
best interest
and that's what a guardian ad litem does
works in the child's best interest
guardian of the items are basically fact
finders but generally make
recommendations with regard to what may
be in a child's
best interest
the court has made it clear that when a
guardian ad litem makes a recommendation
or makes findings of facts those
findings of facts are evidence just like
any other evidence you hear
hears from a guardian that lightened
they consider that to be evidence it's
not a
it's not uh it's get not given
favorable treatment you measure the
credibility of a guardian litem like you
would the parties themselves
you hear what they have to say
you take it into consideration but again
it's just evidence and I can tell you
historically there have been times when
guardian of the volumes have made
recommendations I certainly have found
the other way because I didn't think
that was the right thing to do let me
interrupt to say the uh breadth of
latitude of judges in family court is
one of the major issues before us so
thank you for addressing that and that's
helpful yeah
um
the
guardian of items in terms of the
Guardian the light on board uh we act on
complaints that come in to the guardian
that light on board
um
one of the things I think has happened
since we've had the guardian ad litem
board
is that we have a more professional
group of people because basically they
have to go through a training process
they understand that there are standards
that they have to follow
and if they don't follow those standards
they're subject to discipline and we do
when it's appropriate impose discipline
on guarding that items
at different levels I mean the worst
being the fact that they would no longer
be able to serve in that capacity in
those circumstances
we do not get involved just like you're
in circumstances where you don't want to
be involved in the middle of cases uh
the guardian of the light and board
cannot get involved in the middle of a
case so if you just don't like what the
guardian Enlightenment is saying or
doing we're not going to get involved
with that the case has to be complete in
order for the guardian ad litem board to
get involved and to make a determination
as to whether a guardian ad litem acted
properly
the guardian Adel items we have many
across the state we probably could use a
lot more
uh that we used to have a lot more back
when it was
um when there were a lot more cases when
back in prior to 2008 when we had
uh when the system allowed for
appointment and the state was funding
guarding that items there was a lot more
uh activity wood Guardian little items
judges in terms of discretion if you're
talking about discretion of Judges
judges they were two circumstances
particularly in marital cases
where you
have guardian of items one is the
parties
what you find is that people with
attorneys
particularly experienced and capable
will pick their own Guardian at items
because they know who is good and who
will do a great job for them or what
Guardian Ad Litem skills fit their
particular case
so in those circumstances
the guardian let him get picked that way
in other cases where people don't have
the experience don't know the guardian
of the items they rely on the court to
pick the guardian and light them when
the court judge picks a guardian that
light and they're going to do their best
to try to pick someone that would be
appropriate for the circumstances
so if
if the case was a case where one parent
wants to move out of state
and the question is where is Johnny
going to live is Johnny going to live in
New Hampshire or is Johnny going to move
and you know what's in the child's best
interest
well you're going to pick a guardian to
light him and you'd want a Guardian Ad
Litem that might would have the skill to
make that type of determination whereas
if you had
you know a very contentious you had a
very contentious case with people
fighting and the issues like indicated
early with drugs on one side and
domestic abuse on the other you might
want guarding that item with skills to
handle those types of cases and you get
get to learn the skills of guarding as a
judge you learn the skills of a guardian
the guardian ad litems over time some
are much more capable of dealing with
certain types of cases than others some
as I said you can't teach common sense
that's something that you pick up from
the guardian items a lot of people
qualify as guardian the Lions judges
have a tendency to use some of the same
Guardian the litems over and over and
over again because they trust them you
know and and it's the same as appointing
attorneys for cases and because you know
who's competent and you can trust them
to do a good job so you tend to appoint
people over and over again
uh in terms of the biggest concern I
have with regard to the guardian ad
litem board right now is the proposed
chain what what happened regard with
regarding the lighting board it was
taken out of administrative services and
in in The Proposal in House Bill 2 there
was a proposal to take away
the seven-member board that's been
working I think pretty efficiently and
make it a three-member Advisory Board
this was uh and that was taken out of
house bill to
was not put it in the Senate but I
understand that it's an effort perhaps
an effort uh politically to get it into
another bill in the Senate and that
concerns me because I think that will
deteriorate the way and which we've
managed guardian of items and the
quality that we have
um and basically one of the three
members would be an appointment from the
court which uh may put us back where we
were to begin with and I don't really
and I think that's
what I can offer today
is there a differentiation in the
percentage of jils that the court would
wish to appoint
if one or both parties are per se versus
if
to both parties have retained Council
uh
no uh there would not there wouldn't be
any difference I think we'd look at the
type of case and the issues in the case
to make that determination now
I have to say that a different Guardian
that items have different rates and so
you know high-end cases May hire a
guardian that'll item which may who
would charge more for their services
at a different rate
but in terms of the Court appointing
Guardian enlightens it would not make a
difference to the judge
with regard to the type or quality of
the
guardian of item do any gals serve pro
bono
um
I'm not aware of
that it could be that they are but I'm
thank you representative Greg thank you
Mr chairman I actually have two
questions so get ready I'm gonna do
follow-up I just had two oh okay all
right I didn't know if we were allowed
that thank you so much for being here
today and for taking our questions
um I had a couple questions the first
one now in other states I know they have
a different program but kind of similar
it's called parental rights evaluators
so pre which is is pretty pretty similar
one big difference though that I see I
now do the the gals do they have any do
they do any kind of testing like
personality testing when they do this
psychological testing anything like that
that gets submitted as evidence like for
both parents
do they do uh
if I understand your question
you're asking whether or not the
guardian Adel items
uh suggest that there be that type of
testing if they if they I don't know
what they're like in in other states
parental rights evaluators they usually
have some kind of like a psychology
degree a Psychiatry degree because that
way they can evaluate not just what the
parent is telling them but what an
actual like personality test would show
if there are signs of you know sociopath
or anything like that do we have
anything like that within the gal system
no there there's no uh
to the
there's no requirement that the guardian
ad litems have those types of skills
okay okay okay
they potentially could have those types
of skills
but there's no requirement that they
have those types of skills and there
were other states where
uh they have uh like your uh parental
evaluates uh they there are other states
with Guardian ad litems which have
specific and uh agencies for Guardian
Naval items as opposed to our system in
this state where
we
typically with this the typical
informality of New Hampshire we have
Guardian items coming out of the
population but other states have a
dedicated group of Guardian Adela items
usually attorneys to serve as guardian
of items sure okay thank you for that
and then my second question so I know
that specifically when you're working in
cases whether it be social work you know
Victim Advocacy or whatever when you see
a mass amount of cases eventually
there's a part of you it's almost
impossible not to become jaded or not to
say oh I think I know what's going on
here because I've seen 100 cases is
there ongoing education for the Jal so
that to kind of help them work through
that to get rid of those biases and
stuff
yeah
um there there's first of all is ongoing
educational requirements for for the
guardian of items
uh though
that's a that's a very interesting
question because uh the one thing
uh
is uh and I likeness to judges because
uh you know judges they they put these
black robes on us as judges and I think
to make us look smart and and infallible
but judges are just as human as
everybody else and they screw up and
make mistakes at times
and
the same thing with Guardian items
they're human
and so I think that they're subject to
all the
human predispositions and and concerns
that everybody else is
and so I think uh what happens is if I'm
a judge and I'm uh and I see a guardian
Adel item that I think is predisposed in
a particular way
um then I'm not going to use that
Guardian that light them uh I might not
use them in a case where I think that
that predisposition is going to have an
effect at all
uh you know there were some guardian of
items I won't use it or wouldn't use it
all because I just don't think they have
the skill or the ability to do it they
might qualify as a guardian and light
them but they're not necessarily who I
think could do the job right
and
so long and the short is
do I think that
Guardian Lambs can make mistakes do I
think that they're subject to
predispositions and prejudices like
everybody else yeah I think they are and
I think that part of what a good judge
does and part of the court system does
is sort that out to make sure that that
representative Smith
thank you thank you Mr chairman
um we're here looking at the family
court
can you tell us what you see
may or may not be helpful in terms of
how the family court operates vis-a-vis
the judges being trained
um about
the services of gal and uh and how they
should proceed
you know you don't have to answer yeah
no I uh
the chairman directs the witness to
answer
no all right
you know I uh
um
I
I'm not sure I can give a blanket answer
to that really but
the
um
I think
yeah
that's fine yeah I want to give that
some thought before I just speak
um
that's more than acceptable thank you
and for the times when you Ponder this
what we are really looking at is
suggestions and recommendations we're
not critiquing criticizing redoing we're
just saying how do we make a good thing
we'll stipulate the good thing better
yeah uh uh and I I think I can answer
the question now so along the short is I
I think that the
uh
that guiding that item should only be
appointed when they're needed
there are many cases where judges can
make decisions without having to have a
guardian Adel item I think based on the
evidence
and
they when they are appointed they should
be appointed just to serve as a guardian
as an item
because lots of times
I think judges have a tendency to want
to utilize them to assist in parenting
where
I think they should be
fact-finders make a recommendation but
not to get involved in assisting with
the parenting itself and I think that
really
becomes problematic
and
and this is just a matter of opinion so
I'm not sure I'm speaking specifically
from the board uh as a matter of opinion
and other people have heard me say this
but you know the the very first thing
you learn in law school and you're as a
1l and you take your legal process
course is judges wrote a the Court's
role is to decide cases in controversy
and
the operative word there is
to decide cases
not necessarily to solve cases
and the
and if you understand the courts you
know that and particularly in
contentious cases and in divorce cases
you're not going to solve cases and I
think judges
uh tend to
uh when judges tend to want to solve
cases instead of deciding cases that's
and
so long in the short is when you start
using Guardian that items to go beyond
deciding cases then I think
representative long
thank you Mr chairman uh thank you for
your testimony this is
great good stuff
um you you mentioned that gals get
appointed when the financial needs are
met
um
other than parents paying is there
another method
where the financial needs may be met so
there isn't so it's it's uh parental pay
and if I can follow up yeah
and and and that's uh interesting issue
because uh
that sometimes that gets to be
problematic in that uh one parent will
uh one parent will step up to pay and
the other parent doesn't really
necessarily want a Guardian that light
them but one parent will step up to pay
and then the question is
do you appoint a guardian that light him
gonna be pairing from
suspecting that uh do you do you sense
where a guardian ad litem could lean
towards the parent that's paying
I I mean is there any way of judging
whether or not that
could be the case
uh
don't uh
do I think there's any circumstances
where that could happen sure do I think
there's a circumstance where that could
happen I don't think so and I think if
you have a judge that's responsible at
all they're going to make sure that
there's not that type of predisposition
and uh one more one more uh with respect
to uh both parents paying or one parent
paying uh what would you say is the
greater
um
Financial need is it one parent or or
both parents pay
that when when you say Financial need
yeah
I I don't know the answer to that I
don't think okay I couldn't tell you
thank you
I I was a judge in Franklin so
um we didn't have many we didn't have
is there a case where it seems that one
parent is greater of means and can pay
and the other parent is not and might
qualify for public funds so that the
payment winds up balancing out but the
direction is different no public funds
no public funds no matter how poor you
are
representative Smith I could just follow
up sure that was a decision of this body
um in terms of
changing in the budget uh changing the
practice so that there were no public
funds available both the gal and that
happened 15 years ago now well no not
15. yep yeah well around 2008 around the
that's a hypothetical
thank you so much for coming and making
your presentation this is helpful thanks
but I just you
um
Mr chairman I have to call you Mr
chairman because I could call you judge
I could call you I'm calling you Mr
chairman
knowing the work of
of this committee and knowing how
difficult it is going to be
um I think we were all pleased that you
are here today in your capacity is being
on the board of gal is it possible that
in then over the next month or so you
might consider coming
um in Your Capacity as a former judge or
as the former chair of the Judiciary
Committee to talk about what we might
want to consider in terms of making the
family court as good as it could be
I'd be happy to come anytime you ask
thank you
interestingly how my esteemed Vice chair
just basically read from what I was
going to say
how about
Mr chair my eyes aren't good enough to
read what you've written
so you weren't copying off my paper
I love it when a plan comes together
now we're going to be walking slowly
through this because remember what we
need from
the folks in the audience
is data that can be used by US in the
way we're going to evaluate it
and that means specifics as a slice and
if you start to wander into talking too
broadly too generally about the case as
a whole
I'm I'm going to stop you and not
because you don't have something to say
but this isn't the Forum so with that in
mind uh first up Dana Albrecht would you
come up we have a pink card from you it
doesn't say time needed to speak
um do we have our buzzers and sirens and
if I told them at four minutes and 30
seconds we have a most pleasing and
comforting tone at five minutes it's an
outrageously gross buzzer
so
it's the sign yes
oh is that the comforting one or the
obnoxious one okay don't don't don't do
the obnoxious one we won't need it go
ahead sir thank you for the record Dana
Albrecht uh I'm gonna use my first 30
seconds here to play for you 30 seconds
of audio from the May 1st 2014 Hearing
in Sobel B Sobel
and where was it uh Nashua Family Court
recording yes
uh before the timer continues uh the
attorney sorry representative Macbeth
your question
is uh yeah I do have a question I I just
know that I believe that before the
family court can be recorded it needs to
be approved by the judge it has to be an
order and so I'm just making sure that
we're
listening to something that's lawfully
reporting I just uh actually attest to
that
their public hearings Petition of unions
Petition of Union Leader 2002. okay I
can't rule on that and I'm not going to
um it's just we will take your word you
may do this so chairman they are public
hearings but there are rules in place in
the court regarding how they can be
recorded and I don't have a problem with
listening to anything that's accurately
um so
I'm going to I'm going to ER on the side
let us know to the contrary
um we will make changes accordingly
um my concern about liability is not us
it's about the people bringing things to
us
so what you just heard
was a guardian of item Kathleen
sternenberg and former judge Julie
introcasso uh stating on the record uh
in this hearing May 1st 2014 that they
are very good friends
and I do assure the committee this was
lawfully obtained uh through a request
for the courts for recording and I have
no desire to play the whole hearing for
you that's the 30 second slice that's
relevant thank you
and to your point now and to my point is
that spawned nine cases involving a
conflict of interest
in which uh uh mrtenberg practiced and
actively participated in court cases
before uh Julian tricasso that's my
first point
uh also to the point here on my computer
I have a 154-page PDF which I am not
going to read to the committee no you're
not but it will decide chapter and verse
uh so this is the first two for
background this is the uh February 8th
2021 deposition with exhibits taken of
Miss intercostal as part of a misconduct
uh investigation
uh so I would refer to the committee to
uh
I'd say page 61 this is one of those
depositions where you've got four per
page uh chair is going to interrupt for
a minute and you're using names which
um I would prefer you now to refer back
as title the titles and and the reason
for that is we're looking at process and
not the individual granted the
individual did the process but I would
rather minimize the articulation of
names so you can say the guardian ad
litem the judge the lawyer the
plaintiff's lawyer the defendant's
lawyer you can use those terms if you
would please
okay
uh I would just like to read 61 line 21
of this deposition
uh
I'm sorry their names here uh
the question is
yeah
ah got it the question is from Philip
waystack whose title is Council for the
judicial conduct committee and refer to
him as such in the future
okay so Council for the judicial conduct
committee asks
uh former or at that time current judge
Julie interconto judge judge
was there any discussion at all with you
uh for you and the parties is
for the council that uh Guardian Ad
Litem Kathleen sternenberg was on your
conflicts list
and the answer from Judge intercasso hey
hey come on pay attention to me sorry
titles
not names thank you continue
the marital master has known that for
seven years
thank you so if we do the math on that
this is 2021 okay and that goes back to
2014. so the mineral master has also
known about this conflict since 2014.
so the slice you're giving us
is to the problem of
conflicts conflicts and the allegation
regarding the conflict is that it would
uh the allegations is this likely was
very profitable for the guardian litem
over the course of these
uh nine cases
the allegation is parties from some of
these night cases May in the future
provide different slices for you so you
might wish that background
uh the allegation would be that the
judge did not keep picking the guardian
ad litem because the judge in the
judge's opinion saw that Guardian Ad
Litem as an expert as per judge Gordon's
testimony to us but rather there was
some Financial benefit that would be
gained by the guardian at lighthome
irrespective of whether the guardian ad
litem was qualified or not exactly
that's your assertion exactly I mean
that was a leading question I realized
but yeah exactly up here so yeah one
that's helping us all here okay uh I'm
not sure how we're doing on time we're
doing all right okay
uh so my second slice okay again from
this document would be exhibit 17. of
uh in
exhibit 17 is a order in my family law
case
dated
uh
October 16th uh
2016.
which is one of these appointments in
which the marital Master knowing of this
conflict since 2014
recommended the appointment of this
guardian ad litem
which was then approved by the two
the judge
uh who was
close friends as you heard of the audio
of this Guardian lit item so it's the
second occasion of the same allegation
exactly okay
there are nine occasions we've heard a
representative two of them and you've
attested to nine so yeah skip all of
um the take it out of the micro in 30
seconds please okay okay uh net result
is uh I was charged over ten thousand
dollars in fees for an investigation for
relocation of my children to California
which is why they're now in Michigan
uh
we can pick that up later with questions
and I would like to address one other
I think that we're going to save the one
other for another time
if we may
I can do it in 30 seconds
I'm gonna hold you to it okay
um representative Gordon said uh it was
a point to for judges decide issues of
controversy I would like to know when
there was no controversy why sue espante
my case has now been shipped to Michigan
when I asked opposing counsel the judge
to sign opposing council's proposed
your testimony and for the record I
specifically picked Mr Albrecht to be
first
because he's a regular participant in
our children and family law committee
hearings and
um I figured if I could yell at anybody
it would be it would be somebody I know
oh you're welcome to yell at me well we
do we we could use a little more of that
style here yeah I thought you would be
one
um who could handle that representative
long question thank you Mr chairman um
so can you tell me what brought that
conversation to be of the judge and the
gal they're very good friends
what there had to be a preface to I mean
I think I don't think a judge would say
oh there's Mary her and I are great
friends it it was there something that
led to that
conversation between them uh that's
actually the beginning of the transcript
uh and the audio
uh you got a little thing before that so
they're essentially letting the council
and the courtroom know that they're very
good friends so in
that case sort of people were informed
and then the rest of these nine cases
not so much
okay and uh chill up yeah follow up just
for clarification the judge you're
referring to is no longer a judge that's
any questions
representative Macbeth thank you
um and thank you for taking my question
so uh just to follow up and give it the
context uh the conversation that you
played for us thank you
um was that the um the judge the judge
and the Gael trying to inform Council
and ask if they reveal the conflict and
then ask if if they should continue or
if they wanted them to recluse
themselves
there really wasn't much of a
conversation after that presumably if
they did want to recuse or they would
have had an opportunity to do so I'm
welcome to provide the whole transcript
to the committee if you would like
uh the point of that was to sort of
factually establish that there is was a
conflict
uh I would accept the portion only the
deal specifically with matters of
recusal that apparently were not granted
exactly I would take that slice only not
the rest of the trial please yeah okay
any further questions representative
Alexander thank you Mr chair is there
any sort of requirement that the that
there's a disclosure of a conflict or or
a relationship between the parties uh
the code of judicial conduct would
require that unfortunately that didn't
happen in these nine cases
so if I could follow it happened and
follow up one of those cases
uh well yeah they were informed in in
[Music]
measure of potential conflict was
disclosed in cases two and following did
I hear uh now
in any of them
uh no in fact that's actually what lad
when and it was sort of discovered it
came out in the union leader in October
and that sort of sparked a whole okay
so mandatory disclosure of potential
conflict of interest was not stated by
yeah that's correct over the course of
these cases neither the judge nor the
marital Master nor the guardian ad litem
also all three of these individuals had
a responsibility in all of these cases
to disclose that would be a separate
file
I mean a separate issue I think
okay thank you thank you so much no
it sure recognizes Mr Robert tangway and
uh you've kind of seen the form I don't
know you as well so I'm not going to
yell as loud at you but that's kind of
the form that helps us get what we need
and we try to keep names to a minimum uh
you may introduce a name at the
beginning and then refer by title
because we're really looking for issues
to fix rather than people
thank you you're welcome my name is
Robert tangway I'm a father of two
children which I have not seen since
December 1st 2022 in which fictitious
and false domestic violence allegations
there was no claim of any physical or
sexual violence there was no evidence
presented at the hearing
it was conducted with judicial referee
Joseph Maloney and that will be the only
time that I say that she was a Judicial
referee that hearing was on December
13th
two thousand twenty two
she issued her final orders on December
14th while she presented false findings
of facts physically and mathematically
and possible findings of fact to
the Jew the the judge who signed off on
that I wrote an emergency notice of
false findings of fact presented them to
her where I spelled everything out
and
said that there was no findings effect
no no basically just blew it off just to
keep it simple I proceeded with three
more
and now we're at the Supreme Court right
now
and which I believe its Supreme Court
rule 21 a is called
a
uh where where they're not supposed to
recuse they're supposed to disqualify
themselves if they know they're supposed
to go ahead and disqualify themselves
and what we have here in the state of
New Hampshire is the New Hampshire
women's Bar Association which is not
associated with the bar association yet
what they do is they gerrymander the
lower courts specifically the circuit
courts the family courts and they say so
on their website in which one of our
justices is a paid member of that Lobby
and you're not supposed to have any
effect or or consideration on Race
religion and gender
um so that was those orders were on
December 14
2022 it has bled into with judge previt
in the family matter because she filed
the
domestic violence
case against me to get strategic
benefit in the family case when I filed
a motion to order to have the court
order mediation which they have to in
the family Rules so you're going to want
to look at the rules I'm not going to
submit any paper evidence but anyways
the judge in the parenting case
brought judicial notice that judicial
notice was that I
committed a crime
which
the crime was and he impeached me and in
writing where he impeached me
for
the domestic violence
false mathematically and physically
impossible
findings of fact
by a a so he impeached me and then he
did this judicial notice and then the
judicial notice I have obviously
objected to it requires as part of that
rule
for one I didn't commit a crime I was
never charged with the crime
and if part of that rule is that
I can ask a mandatory hearing on that
judicial notice which he denied then
at the end of April
he literally Broke My First Amendment
right to petition the court by kicking
and and petition basically this court
the court system in New Hampshire as
attested in the last meeting
where the justices were actually here or
the uh the head Justice
it's not they're not following the rules
RSA 173b is unconstitutional
in the state of New Hampshire right of
the accused Article 15 no subject shall
be held to answer for any crime or
offense until the same is fully and
plainfully substantially and formally
described to him or be compelled to
accuse and furnish evidence against
himself every subject shall have the
right to produce all proofs and that may
be favorable to himself to meet
Witnesses against him face to face and
to be fully heard in his defense by
himself and counsel no subject shall be
every person held to answer in any crime
or offense punishable by deprivation of
Liberty your children because that's
what you can do when you uh accuse
they have the right to counsel at the
expense of the state if need is shown
okay we'll ask you to wrap it up Sir
about 15 20 seconds so
I guess the point of my testimony at
this point is to show that I want you
guys to be very hard on the justices
there are laws 633 colon 4 interference
with custody out of state
with no justification it's a class B
felony and the police are Prosecuting on
the laws and the justices aren't it goes
U.S Constitution state constitution laws
court rules that's the order that it
goes and the the court has only
discretion of the court rules because if
you look at all right we're going to
wrap it up yep article
uh sorry article 29 suspension of laws
by register legislator only the power of
suspending laws or the execution of them
uh never be exercised but by the
legislator thank you for your time thank
you sir do you have anything written for
us
it's time on Tech and I appreciate
everybody's time
well well sorry the the clock was about
you speaking I forgot about my
colleagues up here which oh perfect uh
how could I do that a representative
long
thank you Mr chairman uh thank you Mr
tangway so I'm just trying to get the
complaint is due process is that
exactly what the the first gentleman
spoke about conflict
a conflict not just conflict but what
we're looking at is what what happened
in this gentleman's case is it was in
the papers the judge actually
white-outed papers for the gal she
Whited it out
and that's why she's no longer a judge
so
the judge
wrote false statements
mathematically and physically false
statements and just said I don't have a
lawyer by the way the plaintiff was
represented with the lawyer and I filed
the claim 633 colon 4 interference with
custody of class B felony with a 30-day
written admission of it
and she didn't hear it I didn't get a
hearing we're not they're not people
aren't getting hearings in courts on the
family courts process thank you okay
yes representative guitar
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
for taking my question you referenced um
I believe it was RSA 173b and stated you
felt it was unconstitutional which part
of that were you stating I'm I apologize
so
the reason and thank you for asking that
there is in order to be found have a
protection order in 173b to be granted
you must be accused you must have
committed a crime
so therefore the process is not as
many judges wrote the process you're
supposed to report a crime the police is
supposed to investigate and rest that's
simple and then you can add additional
protection orders but what they're doing
is they're curtailing the system as a
shortcut and I believe this is
specifically the women's Bar Association
which if you go to their website and I
have that it has says that they're
working with women judges officials
they're actually doing that it's the
court curtail as a shortcut to any type
of due process which is constitutionally
protected and to do so on offers of
proof which is against court rules you
cannot get a restraining order shall not
be issued on Court rule uh on offers of
proof so they're basically just the
lawyers just testifying lying
and uh saying whatever she has to say so
that they can get protective orders and
what they're doing is they're taking
away your right your Liberty to be with
your children the issue children they
issue property they can issue uh
payments of money it's unconstitutional
in any way
and the only way that it could be
considered constitutional was is with
the domestic courtroom protocol
which I also have that
um and that
was not followed in this case and it's
seeing no further questions thank you
sir thank you so much
and we're all figuring it out as we go
along
but you know what we're trying to do
yeah so thanks uh the reason why I'm
here today is is
I guess so to put it into specifics
there's probably a lot of things and
I'll probably have to come back multiple
meetings but the big one is the uh the
inherent bias of the court system to
give custody of the children to the
mother when it currently appears through
U.S national statistics that actually is
probably the worst case scenario for
children
giving children over to a single mother
home has increased
suicide rates increased Dropout rates
from school
just about every single statistic that
we're looking to avoid in public
increases
when you give children
to to a single mother home
I'm experiencing this personally through
my own divorce situation
but when I read this and and you look
into it
and you try and get the stats to to
confirm that through the state of New
Hampshire they don't keep any stats on
this stuff at all
they keep no stats on the outcomes of
children
I can tell you when I go into the
courtroom this certainly doesn't ask how
are your kids doing
I've never I've as many times I've been
in the courtroom probably a half a dozen
times over seven and a half years still
ongoing and not once the judge ever
asked how the kids are doing
this last go-around I had to convey to
where that
all my kids at this point are adults and
there's still a contention going on with
child support
that they're basically floundering
their mother is
encouraging them to stay at home with
her all the adult children mind you my
kids are not
engaging in their future if you will at
least not to the extent you expect for
the age that they're at
and that in general would be less likely
to happen
if there was a father involved which I
was not allowed to be other than through
visitation you literally become
basically just a guest in your
children's lives
that's the best you can expect
you can't you can't offer anything of
any kind of substance a parent advice or
because you're basically just a guest in
their life
you don't get equal time with the kids
by default even if there is no situation
where there is I mean it was it was
presented when it's like in my example
of my case where
my kid's mother
basically went into the courtroom and
said I'm afraid that was it
that's all it took and that's what the
judge put in the decree she also I had a
communication with my oldest daughter
who at the time was an adult that she
needed to get her together
my ex used that that line as a form of
abuse
and part of the decree why they took my
it's absolutely ridiculous and the
national autistics are horrible
absolutely horrible
you look at just just the incarceration
rates of single mother homes
it's a nightmare
yet we continue to assume that the best
place for children is with their mother
and we don't keep stats on that we just
assume it I've actually asked for
requested information on that and you go
through the court system and they
literally tell you we don't keep those
stats
we just assume that the best place is
for the mother and it's awful
and the outcomes the overall comes is
disastrous for us as a civilization
Mr Savoy are now starting to repeat it
and could you take would you take some
questions from us
absolutely number one for me
uh you made an assertion that the
national statistics say could you
present documentation to this committee
oh I would I would love to but but what
happens is is they keep the you can get
those stats basically through uh news
reports coming out of uh you know there
are institutions that they will allow
this information you have to basically
be a research institution to get this
information and they will allow that to
now be disseminated to these news
reporters or whatever after they've put
it together okay since you know about it
yeah I'm sure you read it yes and in
that case I'd like a copy of it okay a
second thing is it's actually quite easy
you can go right onto Google because I'm
underpaid and over business
because you're trying to convince us
could I ask my research uh staffer
um I believe that there are states where
it has been stated and I grant that's a
broad term where co-parenting is the
expectation unless solid good reasons
otherwise I would like to know that you
know do us tell me some states also what
is that determinant presently in New
Hampshire what's considered best
practices in New Hampshire
um and and once again I would just
suggest to you that the reason there
were no statistics available in New
Hampshire is almost no statistics
available in New Hampshire for almost
anything because we are statistic phobia
in this state and I can't run my deaf
and hard of hearing committee as well as
because nobody will how can you possibly
do your job effectively if you don't
have this kind of data thank you you're
making my point any other question any
questions from anybody up here
representative long
thank you Mr chairman uh so you you
mentioned both your kids were taken away
and you have visitation so which one I
have four kids one was already an adult
so there was three kids basically I you
know I don't want to say taken away
because I still had limited visitation
not because of there was any finding of
of abuse or anything like that although
that is what she tried to claim and she
certainly got you know me kicked out of
the house I'd live out of my car for a
while
just so that she could get me out of the
house which is which is the game they
play they they basically that's that's
how they work they set it up so that
they you kick the father out of the home
right now you have now you have custody
of the children inherently you go
through the whole separation process
which is just awful and supposedly like
in my case it was a um I forget what
they call it but it's it's a um
you know a non-contentious divorce kind
of deal and so they go in supposedly the
easier path if they do that you go in
and they still instead of it being
non-contentious they you know my ex
basically brought forward everything
under the sun as if it was as if I was
doing some kind of abuse link then there
was never any finding in that eventually
the judge did give me what she said was
equal custody which is not equal custody
basically I got better than every other
weekend which is what most dads get
apparently I I got better than that I
actually was able to see my kids every
weekend but in the overall time of your
kids that are there in terms of their
free time when they're not in school or
whatever that it's not equal it's not
like I got equal time I got to see him
on the weekends and then the whole rest
of the time it was
it was mom had him I use a saying that
all kinds of accusations were made
against you by your ex that were not
investigated as to fact uh well they
were they were only basically presented
as hearsay so it was really known that
there was the uh for the reason the
judge didn't feel that there was a need
to do an investigation there was like no
implementation of a guardium and light
what they do is is that
all it takes is the mother to say
anything negative about the father they
grant them the the ability to kick the
father out of the home in the best which
into the best interest of the children
right everything is claimed under the
best interest of the children It
ultimately comes down to you know the
the they'll even tell you and it's even
it's even in the the circuit court rules
that ultimately all none of this matters
other than the best interests of the
children and that's exactly what the
judge uses in order for their outcomes
they'll they'll state in the best
instance of the children
XYZ and that's how it works when we take
another question here uh yeah uh
representative Lanza
so what I I would like to ask you thank
you for taking my question is
um
when was this heard
who when was your case heard where was
it heard
so in my case
um it was is uh Hillsborough County in
Goffstown
a Family Court division
uh so it's been ongoing is still ongoing
and it's been going on for seven and a
half years so we'd like to know the date
when the allegations were made against
you I can get that to you I don't know
if that would be helpful or filed so we
can go back and look yeah it's not that
we don't doubt you but you know trust it
but oh no absolutely I can even get you
I'll get you the you know the uh Court
the court docket number that'd be nice
right and it's you just look at the
divorce decree it's and the judge
outlines the reason for
how she broke down who got the contract
sister chills and all that stuff you
just read the decree and it's right
thank you so much I apologize
representative Lance I jumped in the
middle of your question do you have
anything for me
no thank you I I think I got all my
information right now when especially
when he sends any information back to us
thank you absolutely thank you
representative anyone else represented
to ball
thank you chairman Pearson
were you offered and thank you for
coming and taking my question
um were you offered any free guidance or
assistance through the courthouse When
you entered the courthouse yeah that's
that's a great question so you know in
order to get free Assistance or
something like that
um you've got to meet a certain
threshold you have to be under a certain
threshold of income kind of kind of
thing I did not fall into that mainly
because uh I I have I have a good income
I have a uh
high value house and it's you know
nearly paid off and I also have a good
retirement account what I didn't have
was direct access to you know available
cash
my mistake I didn't I didn't know at the
time that I should be saving up money
for a divorce because it kind of I was
blindsided by that so
did you rep follow-up
um thank you just to clarify so there
was no one in the courthouse to help you
fill out paperwork or how to address
I understood so I mean I was able to
fill it out almost I mean in terms of
like an attorney or something like that
they the judge tells you right up front
you really should get an attorney
and typically that's going to cost you
12 000 up front that's what the judge
told us and that's just to get the ball
started with the attorney right I didn't
have twelve thousand dollars on hand so
that wasn't happening and only that
in talking to my peers going around and
I talked to many of them and my
co-workers my peers and all that kind of
stuff and the ones that did get the
their attorneys if you will
they said that
they like the fact that the attorneys
kept them giving a certain amount of
money to their exes
but
almost all that money they would have
given to their ex they wanted given to
their attorney anyways and that happens
100 of the time across the board so I
said I came away you know
there wasn't really a lot of benefit to
having an attorney
and it became clear to me that by
default mom gets the kids anyways
and I didn't really have a claim and I
was you know as as a practicing
Christian myself I wasn't going to be
making claims against her falsehoods
against my ex
in order to try and try and somehow get
custody and and I I'm glad I did not do
that because the whole goal between the
attorneys is basically throw as much
stuff against the wall and hopefully
some of it sticks and when you're on the
receiving end of that let me tell you
that sucks a lot and that's exactly what
to do the her my ex's attorney she just
threw as much stuff up there true or not
against the wall and you got and they so
they her being the plaintiff she goes
first the attorney for for my ex she
went first she gets to throw all this
stuff up against the wall and you got to
sit there and try and go through and
defend each one of them and if you don't
defend against them effectively you're
guilty of that
as you get in there and you basically
have to prove your innocence thank you
um I'm hearing your um your ex-wife was
um
had counsel and you went uh per se
correct
um which is an inherent disadvantage and
you're too rich to uh get something for
free but you're too poor to be able to
afford something that's right I fell
into that window where it's there is
something worth looking at okay any
and seeing none and I think we got about
enough pink cards for the time remaining
so thank you sir
thank you
and I think you've seen How We Roll here
and uh
thank you chair special committee my
name is Randall Collier
um
I like everything that's been said here
there's been a lot of fallacy there's
been a lot of misconceptions
um there's been a lot of good questions
um so I right now I have a 48 million
dollar suit in a Supreme Court
through Belknap County Court
um
Declaration of Rights 24 violations due
process I know I spoke in front of this
committee before yep
um
so there's a lot of things that I
brought to the Supreme Court's attention
and a lot of people are obviously
suffering at the hands of these family
courts
first of all
um when you go into family court and
they give you a paper
um
say for criminal threatening or domestic
violence once again
allegations were unfounded
um the court says that they gain
jurisdiction
over the parties
um this is on the 12413 order that's
going on for 12 years
uh the court says they found evidence by
this order that it has jurisdiction over
the parties and subject matter and the
defendant upon service will be given
reasonable notice and opportunity to be
heard
I I hereby certify that I have read and
recommendations and agreed to the extent
the mayoral Master judicial referee
hearing officer has made factual
findings and applied the correct legal
standards and facts determined by the
Maryland Master judicial referee
signed by the Belknap County Judge
however
that's actually a illegal uh
unconstitutional way to gain
jurisdiction over the party's uh legally
you need three elements uh subject
matter person am and territorial so I
guess a long time ago family courts are
removed from superior court and now
they're part of the equity court and not
a criminal court
so
these Family Court judges like to remove
our constitutional rights to our
children
um without actually a criminal hearing
and then they deny access to evidence to
defend against the judge's findings I
want to bring special attention to you
guys since you guys have this committee
up
um okay we're going to need a specific
because so far I've heard a very broad
generalization that I've heard about
1100 times since I got to the
legislature seven years ago what I want
is a specific example from you well
specific examples of equity Court judges
can't have subject matter jurisdiction
over people okay because Equity core is
finances and property only and the only
way in a constitutional republic as a as
an American is through Criminal Court in
a jury of your peers and be able to
access evidence to defendant which we're
all I'm going to back you up because I I
don't write as fast as you talk Equity
Court your your allegation is that
family court or Family Division of
Circuit Court
should not be hearing these cases
correct they have no legal ability right
so family court and will you provide us
with paperwork that backs up what you
believe 32 pages right here okay well
that's why I have two clerks okay sorry
continue
um so they they say they gain
jurisdiction over the parties but they
legally don't
um secondarily
um person am jurisdiction has to be met
in order to take it rights away and
that's actually being wanted for a crime
um which means there's evidence of
Corpus still like die in three elements
of an actual crime against somebody to
have your parents removed or have your
parental rights removed from your kids
so this has been going on for 12 years
I've seen my son four years four times
in 10 years for a total of six hours so
um
the other allegation is not primarily I
mean it's it's Downstream what they did
your Chief allegation is they had no
business to do this in the first place
irrespective of what their decision was
it was the wrong venue constitutionally
Not only was it the wrong venue but then
they violated all the state statutes and
federal law in hearing the case so it's
I love this phrase fruit of a poison
tree go on yeah so
um I know representative long we spoke
last time uh and we I think it was
regarding the troxible versus Granville
case the parrot the parental alienation
I think it was you
um however uh since then uh New
Hampshire Supreme Court has also ruled
uh in the Miller versus Todd case uh
that false allegations is enough to
overturn custody and and family court
should have never granted uh primary
custody to the mother on the false
allegations uh however uh New Jersey's
Supreme Court just ruled two years ago
and I want you guys all to
uh okay let's give it to the North
Carolina Supreme Court
um in 2000 uh
gotta wrap it up okay uh North Carolina
Court Supreme Court granted the father
uh 300 an hour for every hour that the
family court took uh him away from his
daughter he was granted 3.1 million and
the dollars granted 1.5 uh New Jersey
Supreme Court uh two years ago
just
put out an order and it said
um
well the New Jersey Supreme Court said
uh September 27 2021 they clearly
explained how these family courts cannot
lawfully shift the burden of proof to a
parent to prove they did not commit the
offense such as abuse in this case to uh
justify infringing on the rights of
Parental uh rights over their child so
there's been multiple Supreme Court
cases that have ruled that family courts
don't have the ability to take or give
parental rights that's only through
actual criminal process
um
so not not only is all these family
courts trying to gain jurisdiction over
the parties illegally they violate State
I am a sajiel bear but I've been walking
to watching too many hockey games lately
is it Gilbert or Gilbert
okay
sir
all right you gotta hit it again I'll
keep my hands off the button here thank
you thank you thank you uh chairman
Pearson and committee I first want to
follow up with uh some of what was
already testified here today uh first
off with what representative ball
recently just asked is if there was uh
parties within the court system that
could provide assistance with filing
um what I have recognized over the last
13 years of being in the Family Court
division uh is that the clerks at least
in the sixth district
and also down in Cheshire County uh are
very uh apprehensive of assisting filers
with processing things
um stating that it's a conflict of
interest uh for them to assist with that
um so I do feel that uh that's something
that should be addressed that Clerk
should be obviously not particularly
stating out what needs to be filed but I
do need to state that you know they
should be assisting people that are less
fortunate with understanding or having
disabilities have that accessibility to
file
moving forward I would like to follow up
with Gordon Ness uh sorry Ned Gordon
uh and with regards to the guardian
items
um we in my 13 years in the family court
I'm obviously a young gentleman uh on my
children I was birthed when I was 17
years old
um that being said we have had extensive
I've had probably 15 different Garnett
items over the 13 years uh some that
were voluntarily recused some that were
forcefully recused
um I I do feel that the family courts do
go ahead and over extend the processing
of providing a Garnier item when they
could be
particularly piecing these pieces
together just from the testimony from
the parties
um and they are utilizing these Guardian
items more as an investigative and
Parental Guidance rather than
you know actually conducting best
interest determinations
um
following up with the division and this
is my main point here that I wish to
speak and I do wish to come back and
speak further when I have a proper set
of guidelines fourth so I can lay those
grounds but following up with dcyf and
Mr ribsum uh
primarily what my testimony will be here
today and in future sessions is I do
believe and I believe that you're going
to find out for many constituents as
well as from the judges themselves that
this Family Court division issue is
primarily due to dcyf non-compliance
with their own policies as well as with
RSA 169 C and 170 g8ab
what's the last reference 170 GAA
which is the records of the division and
the court
to follow up with that on that notion
alone uh and I'm sure judge Gordon can
follow up with this further is with Casa
there is a very lack of oversight on
Casa themselves there is a lack of admin
rulings and there is a lack of uh
statues for Casa
um they're point blankly in the gal and
under the 169 C guidelines is
um portions that state that Casa's
records are subject to 170 g8a but if
you go through 170 g8a nothing regarding
Casa is mentioned
um so there is some uh statues that are
missing uh definitions and guidance
and what I've seen is a lot of attorneys
and DC wife themselves do not understand
what 170 g8a even in titles or entails
personally with my experience in my
matter is ongoing I'm more than welcome
to give the case number
um
but we've been ordered for over a year
now for dcyf to turn over all documents
all third party documents including
restricted access documents
with that dcyf is refusing
um to follow up into my next point which
I will continue at a later time will be
that I am currently being violated on my
Fifth Amendment right dcyf has requested
that I participate in post-conviction
therapy and post-conviction therapy is
not afforded to me because I'm not even
charged with a Criminal crime my case
has been going on for three and a half
years under the 169 C
and
okay good thank you we'll look forward
to you coming back and if you have
anything for us you can uh you know hand
it in send it to the clerk what have you
yeah yes Mr representative McMahon thank
you Mr chairman Mr Gilbert Just to be
specific the uh directive that you
provided here are specific to dcyf and
not the family court is that correct no
they are Family Court uh rsas for abuse
there was non-compliance by the dcyf not
stating there was not compliance or
appropriate following the rules that's
why we're here with the uh family court
you clarified then what what's going
down here with your case sure thing so
obviously as I'm sure everybody is aware
dcyf provides the proposed orders for
the judge and the judge kind of just
rubber stamps those orders in a sense
obviously we've had a lot of I have a
three-page article from our judge that
contradicts what dcyf has claimed um
but that being a side uh so basically
with that dcyf is proposing these orders
that are unconstitutional that do not
even comply with their own policies do
not comply with 169 C the judges are
then you know unbeknownst to them you
know a judge's I don't foresee is to
know that you know post-conviction
therapy is you know what it is in a
sense uh under what dcyf is proposing
um and obviously it would be a violation
of the Fifth Amendment to require
somebody to go ahead and provide
post-conviction therapy when you're not
convicted
okay thank you very much for that
clarification anyone else
representative Alexander thank you um Mr
chair I'm
I'm just trying to get a little more
detail on you being forced to
participate in post-conviction therapy
was that was that a court order that is
part of the dispositional orders
um for the court correct and if I could
follow up follow up is that
has their in your experience or
experience has this been like a
tradition of the court to do this or I
guess I'm wondering why why you were a
point what the reason was for you to be
appointed to this sure thing so
obviously the Baseline is a 169 C which
is abuse and neglect case uh we won't go
into the specifics today
um barring the requirements under 170
g8a
um that being said
um so with this I in my research in my
follow-up uh with the office of the
child advocate who I hope will testify
before this committee at some point
um and I would welcome them to commit to
testifying
um that this is the first case that New
Hampshire has seen that there is a 169 C
for this type of matter that does not
have a criminal aspect to it
um
so with that uh we'll go along with my
further testimony later on but uh the
division is prolonging these cases again
this is three and a half years the
statutory limit for this type of case is
12 months
um we're going on three and a half years
they're awaiting criminal aspect that is
never going to be afforded in the statue
of limitations on criminal aspect is 40
years
representative Macbeth thank you very
much thank you I just want to clarify so
the 169 you're saying dcyf so they had a
finding of abuse is that what you're
saying and then but there was no
criminal charges and then you're saying
the Court Family Court included that
finding and kind of found you guilty or
of a crime needing the therapy is that
kind of how that fell so it's by the
preponderance of an Evans which is a
belief that something could possibly
happen it is not a conviction it is not
a finding of guilty it is a belief that
by whatever evidence might have been
offered there is a belief under a hint
of a fraction of whatever that may
pertain by the guidelines of the court
it's 51 percent uh belief that something
possibly could happen
are you asserting that what they're
making you do should have only come out
of a higher standard of evidence than
they used
correct it's post-conviction therapy
thank you so much so much for Gilbert
thank you and we'll see you soon
and the last card we're going to use and
thank you for somebody who put in a pink
card saying I want to be first next time
like that uh is uh attorney Paulo uh is
it Remy vermi verm help I want to get it
right
no judge in my entire legal career
attempted to say my name when they first
okay
um start the clock
today I'm talking about General stuff
and I'm actually surprised that uh
ribson
and former judge Gordon which is what I
call him because I was an attorney
um we're here testifying because uh
about the gal
and the dcyf piece of it because
part of my
written testimony and I only have about
six pages of testimony the rest of it
are exhibits that support it
facts that you want
was that ribsum ignored a right to know
and uh judge king ignored it's diff it's
a little different under the judicial
it's a right to know under article eight
it's not under 91a
uh just didn't reply
um
um one thing you and this is off the top
of my head because of uh
some testimony from
judge Gordon uh casa
obviously
has Guardians ad litem
in
the court
they also have a seat at the guardian ad
litem ad litem board
so
uh being part of the body that regulates
yourself
pretty much guarantees that there aren't
going to be any uh discipline problems
against you
with that I don't know if I'll get
through the rest of my five minutes but
I'll I do have it written
uh first of all I'm submitting this
lengthy written testimony at the end
I'm actually surprised I wrote down that
few lay people can explain in five
minutes a laundry list of how they were
wronged and they're doing pretty good
some are knowledgeable some are not
um
another thing the judges okay when you
picked up and this is also in my written
testimony when you move the Family
Matters out of Superior Court
particularly divorce
you moved it from a constitutionally
created Court
to a statutorily created court and part
of what I'm submitting you is the
Supreme Court case that says judges
broad judicial Equity power ends at the
courtroom door in a statutorily created
court so I all the judges and probably
judge Gordon as well
we're making some broad Equitable orders
such as appointing a commissioner to
sell a marital home which they didn't
statutorily have the power to do that
they they used to it was a very old
common law uh right of judges and it
could have happened in Superior Court
um you know they order a parenting
coordinators they all kinds of things
that they're making orders on that are
flat out illegal and I don't have all
the proof in this because otherwise you
would have had a stack that high and I
had one week to prepare this so you're
going to get it a little at a time just
the cliff notes right
um
and the last thing I haven't uh okay
also evidence that Gordon McDonald
ordered a sign on every court room door
in the state about this no recording
without the permission of the judge and
I'm not about to ask any judge to
exercise a constitutional right so I
don't do that
um
he doesn't like me very much because I
sent him an email about that ridiculous
order
um
the other thing is is statutorily
they're the gal is allowed to recommend
a therapist
uh who the judge will then pick
there's going to be later testimony on
why it is such a bad idea for judges to
pick their own Witnesses in cases and it
um and it it really violates people's
rights you know I think you've already
heard there's a pretty short list of
gals there's a shorter list of
psychologists that are willing to do
these evaluations and the judges are
also picking them
um
so anyway
um you know they do things all the time
like order mediation in the presence of
domestic violence
I I found the practice was widespread
um
so I have more they'll be it'll be in
writing and I'll turn it in
thank you so much any questions for the
counselor
ready
I would especially like to have more and
I I don't have to I don't have I know I
don't have to beg you for this uh on
your assertion about moving when the
family court moved from a
constitutionally created Court to a
statutory court that does not have the
right to mandate things beyond the
corridor I'd like to explore that so if
you can give us proofs New Hampshire
Supreme Court opinion is in here
thank you any other questions
may I make one more Point nope
okay thank you
and we are have come to the end of today
it's a hearing
was anybody on the committee has
anything you'd like to
input I think we've got a number of
different kinds of things we might
profitably explore there'll be more
evidence and we're siloing maybe I
shouldn't use that word but we are
vertically putting them into folders
like oh yeah like those folders so that
when somebody comes with something that
goes to that point that evidence goes in
there so one of these days when it's
time to analyze we'll look at them
folder at a time
so representative um Alexander thank you
and I I apologize because I did miss
this organization meeting is your
intention to do some like listening and
then like a day of like talking about it
amongst ourselves I want to do enough
listening that we get a good sampling
under each one of the topics from
different people perfect and then maybe
over the summer uh there'll be some
homework assignments of some Brave
volunteers will
um
read the transcripts of the Court
hearings that have been given to us just
a slice why do we want to do that do we
just believe what people say it's not a
matter of that we just want to make sure
from our perspective that it if anybody
asks we've seen in the court French
script what the person said was there I
think everybody wants that
then I suspect and I'll be talking a lot
with my vice chair but there'll be some
days when we will go through the
different folders of topics and see what
happens but we're kind of feeling our
way along Madame Vice chair
yes thank you um this is all one packet
um Mr chair would um
you consider it appropriate to ask
um OLS perhaps Mr Lambert or someone
else to give us a brief
um
explanation of the issue involving the
difference between a constitutional and
uh and a constitutionally established
court and a statutorily established
Court particularly in terms of equity
Authority
we are blessed by having Christina Dyer
and Richard Lambert okay and there's so
much work here that I don't think
they're going to fight over who gets
what so we'll talk about is this one
you'd like or would you like this to go
next door and
because either one of you will do a
great job
so some one of the two of them I'm sure
will tell us
any other homework for the research
staff
yes representative Macbeth thank you so
much I have a question some of the
material that's been handed in how do we
get copies of that is that going to be
scanned or and sent or print to us or do
we need to contact the
we are working that out with
um Aaron Goulet from the speaker's
office uh Jim ciancie house legal
counsel and the IT crew
uh in terms of what may we and if we may
how should we and that sort of thing
um
I think the uh
Chief of Staff to the speaker Aaron
Goulet has spoken with the clerks
or at least one of the clerks both of
the clerks and so this is a bit of a
work in progress we already have a
number of documents that I've turned in
that will be available such as the two
reports from the 2012 redress of
grievances that's in there we got all
kinds of cool stuff coming and we'll
they my our Clerk
experts here will let us know how we can
do that for those of us who aren't
luddites but have great respect for
their movement there may be some of it
we are finished
sorry
nervous there
okay